Perhaps the biggest nightmare begins
right here, looming over the
industrial revolution, the
displacement of millions of workers
and the loss of
huge number of jobs.
It's funny because everybody's like,
"Oh, robots are stealing our jobs.
And I'm like, "No, humans have been
doing robot jobs." It's
tragic that we're having humans
perform such basic tasks all day." I
think humans have such capabilities
that they should be reserved for
high value things that only
humans can do. If a machine can do
it, then the machine should do it.
So I think that's what's going to
happen. Just spend your entire
day in flow state and do
whatever you do best, and
then a machine should pick your
whole the logistical work around
that.
Software engineer Flo Crivello is
the founder and CEO of Lindy,
which is part of the new Artificial
Intelligence gold rush that could
upend the U.S.
labor market.
To better understand how that
disruption will play out, it's worth
looking at how the intersection of
computing and telecommunications
have already impacted how Americans
spend their working hours.
A.I. furthers what the venture
capitalist Marc Andreessen has
described as "software eating the
world."
Even as the number of employed
Americans grew by 16% from
2000 to 2021, people
working as executive secretaries and
executive administrative assistants
fell by 66%
because of tools like voicemail,
calendar apps, web browsers and
dictation software.
Lindy could drive that number down
even further by creating an AI
personal secretary that can book
travel, take notes during meetings
and handle basic email
correspondence.
The long term vision is to basically
automate all knowledge work, so we
really think of her as an
AI employee of sorts.
Over the same time period as the
overall labor market grew, the
number of travel agents plummeted by
70%, thanks in part
to direct to consumer booking sites.
Now, tools like Tripnotes AI
can build a full travel itinerary
without the hassle of price matching
or spending hours reading up on
whether the ancient Athens store or
the gourmet food tasting are the
better use of an afternoon.
The number of professional
photographers in the U.S.
has fallen by 41% since 2000
because of smartphones and
ubiquitous digital cameras.
Now, startups like Head Headshot Pro
could drive that down with its AI
generated professional headshots
such as this one, which cost me
$29 versus the roughly
$700 that it cost to hire
a human photographer here where I
live in Washington, D.C..
AI tools that already exists could
automate 25% of the tasks
American workers do, according
to a recent report by Goldman Sachs,
which will free up humans to do
other things.
The prediction that I will put us
all out of work is based on a
fallacy, and we can expect
total employment to continue rising
even as technology wipes out
specific jobs.
It's a process of "creative
destruction," to use the phrase of
the economist Joseph Schumpeter,
which explains why whole new
industries emerge following the
disappearance of ice cutters,
blacksmiths, harness makers,
wheelwrights, ditch diggers,
weavers, telegraphist, pinsetters,
lamp lighters, elevator operators,
lectors, clock keepers,
projectionist, milkmen and log
drivers. In the process, we became
profoundly richer.
Technology frees up resources to
create jobs that people in the past
could never have imagined.
And no, this time is
not different.
People mistakenly believe that there
is a fixed amount of work
to be performed in the economy.
The reality of it is that
human needs and wants or
infinite the lifestyle
that you and I live is actually
better than the lifestyle of Louis
the 16th, and we still want more.
In the beginning of the 1900s,
something like 90% of the population
were farmers.
Since then, we went down and
very quickly to 5% of the
active population or something like
that. And yet we don't massive
unemployment, very
far from it in the U.S.
Since 2000, factory automation has
driven
down manufacturing employment, even
though the U.S.
is producing more stuff than ever
before.
On the other side of the ledger,
software development has been one of
the fastest growing professions
since 2000, increasing by
143%
and outpacing the growth of overall
employment.
That trend will probably continue.
AI won't replace coders, but it will
make it possible for the less
technically sophisticated to drive
more sophisticated applications.
And this will enable founders to
bootstrap an idea with minimal
backing.
Similar to how cloud computing
enabled tech startups to bring their
products to market without their own
backend infrastructure.
Crivello predicts that there will be
demand for software applications to
fit every conceivable need
as the economy moves toward more
personalized everything.
When you ask something
to Lindy, the way she performs the
task actually is that she writes a
little piece of code to perform the
task for you.
For example, if you say "Hey help
me find
30 minutes with Bob next week, she's
going to write a
piece of code to be like, "I'm going
to look at your calendar.
I'm going to pull availabilities in
with equal in an email.
I'm going to send them to Bob and
I'm gonna wait for his reply." So
all of that is a mini piece of code.
And I think that's amazingly
interesting because I always compare
it to the Industrial Revolution
where it's like before the
Industrial Revolution, certain goods
like caps of pens were very
expensive.
One cap was probably
of the order of like 100 or 500
dollars, right?
And after the revolution,
these goods became so cheap that
we started to have single use
versions of them.
And so, you know, we have like the
right solo caps and like the bic
pens and they're just so cheap
that you can't even refill of bic
pen. It's just cheaper to buy a new
one than to replace the ink.
And so here it's the same thing
historically, code
has been very expensive.
One app has cost of the order of
$10,000 to $100,000
with the AI cognitive revolution
code is becoming so cheap that it
can be disposable in single use.
And so it costs on the order of
one cent to build an application.
And so effectively you're going to
live in a world where bespoke
mini applications are built for
every little use case that you have
throughout your day. And that's what
Lindy's doing effectively.
If we think about generative AI
right now, I can create
a photo of, you know, Gandalf
wearing a pink shirt in a
silly hat in seconds.
Alex Banks writes the newsletter
Through the Noise and is the
co-founder of Tribescaler, a tool
that uses an AI algorithm to
generate viral social media hooks.
And all of these create a task that
would take a Photoshop expert
hours.
I can now do with a very simple
prompt.
It is leveling the playing field for
creative output, where
those who weren't creative, those
who couldn't tell stories, now can,
and those who were creative are only
getting even better.
I see A.I.
as on demand
intelligence, right?
It's way cheaper
and way faster than what you
can get from humans.
Just because tools like Amper can
generate tracks like this one with
the simple prompt of exciting, fast
paced and a little bit suspenseful.
That doesn't mean that AI will put
the nearly 10,000 Americans working
as music directors and composers
out of a job.
Rather, it'll mean a lot more
individually tailored music.
Tools like Amper will do some of the
work, but it will help composers
work faster, better and free
them up for higher level tasks.
Radio GPT can pick songs, write
scripts and have a realistic
sounding voice read it.
But the demand for human curated
music won't disappear.
The Internet destroyed album sales,
which were once a major source of
revenue, but the number of
professional musicians has still
grown by 76%
since 2000.
Banks and Crivello are working on
systems that utilize GPT-4
and artificial intelligence to do
things that a generation ago would
have been unimaginable.
We have the tools that will
augement human potential.
So Tribe Scaling itself helps
you go viral on Twitter. It's your
AI writing assistant and
personal collaborative.
We use GPT-4 in really two settings.
Number one is to help you by a great
hook. So a hook is the number
one factor in whether your piece of
content succeeds or sits in the
dock. And so the hook is the
absolute critical factor.
And so we use GPT-4 with fine
tune prompts to use
vetted viral structures to help you
write better.
Banks is also currently working on a
project called Aloy, which he thinks
will improve on not taking
applications that are being marketed
as a second brain.
If we look at Notion, it's
a wonderful platform to
store all of your personal knowledge
and it's fairly good at
retreating with some search.
It does a fairly good job, but it
isn't. It isn't entirely robust.
And then you have other platforms,
right, on that capture phase, such
as say Things Three.
That is a wonderful quick capture on
the desktop where
I can hit control spacebar
and I can immediately capture a
thought. But then it's stored in a
central repository and it's up to me
to relocate that thought.
What we're doing with Aloy is
essentially going, okay, how can we
complete that cycle for an
individual and build a
second brain for you so you can
access your creativity on
demand?
If I'm here and I'm wanting to
write a tweet, say, and
six months ago I had a conversation
with my friend Natalie and we were
chatting about AI and there was a
wonderful insight that I got from
that conversation, and I added it to
my second brain.
All on GPT-3.
Now, when I go to write that tweet
and I start to write about GPT-3,
all of a sudden, what Aloy can do
is it could resurface that idea
for you dynamically.
How we think about how that's going
to propel productivity is
really, really vast.
And something that I'm massively
excited for.
Change is scary.
I think we all are about to see
maybe the biggest change in
human history.
That sounds like hyperbole, but I
really believe that. People are
comparing AI to smartphones
or the internet.
I think it's much closer to, I think
it's Larry Samuels who
said, it's much to the invention of
fire or the wheel.
Though the Goldman Sachs report
predicts that 30% of industries
won't be impacted by AI at all.
Some of these tools will free up
human labor for service occupations
like that of food, which hasn't been
fundamentally altered by computing
and has grown nearly 37%
since 2000, outpacing the
growth of overall employment.
The same goes for taxi drivers and
personal trainers.
As Crivello points out, we're
hoarding too much human labor
in existing industries, especially
those controlled by the public
sector.
For example, the federal government
wants to hire 87,000 new
IRS agents when those same people
could be producing goods and
services that other humans actually
value.
Health care administrators have
grown in number since 2000, partly
because of all the red tape that
came with Obamacare.
Technology might have already
started shrinking the education
labor force and new tools like
Course AI that can design syllabi,
or Cognii, which offers one-on-one
AI tutoring, will drive further
productivity gains in the sector.
Remaking how we work is a core part
of every tech revolution, and it's
through this process that we've
profoundly driven up our standard of
living. Let the robots have
their jobs.